Oh
[Music]
so you hear a lot of people are really
freaked out about this idea this meme
singularity some call it the rapture of
the Nerds they feel like technologists
have hijacked the Christian story of God
and heaven in the afterlife just
translated into the language of
electronic technology and synthetic
intelligence and mastering the
information processes of biology so that
we can engender and engineer our own
godhood but I don't really think that
that's a problem I mean those religious
myths that we have been caught up in for
centuries reflect our yearnings to
transcend our own limits you know as
Ernest Becker says we are God's with
anuses with our minds we can ponder the
infinite yet were housed in the heart
pumping breath gasping decaying body
it's up to be godly yet creaturely sort
of amused the human condition with a
sort of bittersweet sort of exquisite
pain quality to it that sort of in a way
drives our creativity our desire to
transcend all previous limits to to
transform the world in our own image
comes from our desire to escape the
death sentence that makes us ultimately
food for worms so I think that the
singularity as a meme that reflects the
sort of acceleration of the human design
process to the point of achieving a kind
of infinite velocity where everything
becomes linked and everything else and
matter becomes mind where we impregnate
the universe with it
jinzo's Eric Davis as written you know
today technologists are these ecstatic
technicians of the sacred they're
figuring out how awareness works how the
self emerges can we create
non-biological intelligence when we
create sentience and a different
substrate that is not found by the
limits of biology we are the frontal
lobes of the universe we are the eyes
and ears of the universe we are a way
for the cosmos to know itself as Carl
Sagan says and our desire to transcend
all previous limits is the universe's
desires therein so I don't think there's
anything unnatural about tad and so for
that reason I think the idea of the
singularity is awesome
[Music]